this guy and she wants to have sex after
marriage and then after they get married
and she has sex with them she meets a
guy at work that has this energy of
being in control I wonder if this has
happened to her sometimes it seems very
specific do I think that most guys would
take a virgin gladly over somebody who
had slept with 100 people 100 the guys
will take damn near anything these days
they didn't really have a choice they
don't really hit on the choice like no
guy expects a virgin guys adapt to the
market what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos today we have a special
guest on the channel welcome Christine
thanks for having me hello everyone so
Christine is our newest talent in the
audacity Network where we have the
audacity to dunk on these women we're
the we have the audacity to speak out
about feminism where we have the
audacity to really just say what's on
our mindset freedom of speech so make
sure you go subscribe to Christine's
Channel we're really trying to get her
monetized this week and make sure you
like the video so as many people can see
this as possible so Christine today
we're arguing and you know talking about
some really tough topics that you know
are really confusing So today we're
watching a clip about how men don't like
promiscuous woman is this triggering to
you men don't like women who sleep
around no they don't this is brand new
information yeah yeah they like no
actually according to the left they are
dying to wife up corn stars and only
fans models that's their first choice
they thought wife and mother makes sense
so um this is Destiny was a nice man
that came here on the show talked a lot
of after which I don't appreciate
they come here they just talk all this
when they leave I'm like wow but
this is his wife and they're in an open
marriage meaning they both and sleep
with other people do you understand why
guys
um would have a problem with the one
with a high body count though do you
understand the logic behind us I think
it's insecurity that's where it comes
from it's like do they really want to
have a woman that is just a virgin
because she's not gonna be good and
she's gonna have no experience they
don't need you to be good though that's
so boring isn't that it's boring that's
so boring I'll tell you what that's so
like just it just sounds transactional
to me you know what's so funny about
this topic about sex and women it's so
funny because as a as a man I seem to
have more knowledge about female anatomy
than most women there's one thing I know
growing up with around women having
sisters is that the woman's anatomy is
so delicate that she could get infection
simply from just sitting on a toilet
simply from sitting in the wrong place
maybe even using her underwear more than
once like just the little things so
imagine 10 different dicks going in
there that's crazy and some of them go
as far as having those dicks in the same
day that is crazy but you don't want a
woman with experience kid
aren't you gonna be bored like what is
she gonna she's like coming with no it's
like a job shouldn't she come in with
some experience if I'm a man that needs
a woman with experience then I I'm not a
man that should be in a relationships do
I see it a man is meant to lead a man is
meant to start a family protect provide
pass down information so like I don't
see why a woman needs all this
experience going into a relationship
unless she wants to be the man in the
relationship like turning us into man
don't understand her logic how is it
insecure security to not want to share a
woman and I think that's I think that's
masculine in its Essence like you know
that's that's my woman and you know no
one else has access and scarcity
determines value though I don't get why
people find this so hard to understand
you know what else I wonder like if we
say I want a tall man does that make me
insecure no no it's like it's like women
can say whatever and it doesn't make us
insecure no but if a guy is like yeah I
don't want my wife who have sucked a lot
up you know like that's just not my
thing yeah then he's insecure or or I
don't want my wife to be seriously
overweight oh well he's insecure he
should like fat it just sounds so
boring I don't know that's very strange
too it sounds transactional for a
version I like you because you haven't
been with anyone yeah it's like you
haven't been to it I know that's why I
like you I think that's crazy I don't
know I don't that doesn't make sense to
me at all well you can understand first
of all well crazier than oh I like you
because you've been with everyone
also no one's saying that's the only
reason a man would like a woman but it's
about preference in the same way as
height it's just something that makes it
a lot better well and the same way we
would disqualify a man for being five
foot like that's pretty shallow I don't
think it's shallow for a guy to say oh I
don't want to date a chick because she
slept with 50 men it just makes it a lot
harder for them because
most probably have yeah they're
religious that that comes from a
different place right yeah of course
yeah okay guys that are alpha guys that
are you know
um want to be you know head of
households and consider themselves
leaders and want to you know provide for
their women and they don't they don't
find it unattractive that a woman would
have inexperience because they feel like
you know what's gonna make that
experience in the bedroom so powerful is
not that she can bounce off the walls or
knows all these tricks or knows all
these sexual things and oh she looks oh
look she's doing something like out of a
porno you know that's not what's
appealing to them what's appealing is
that she's really excited to be there
for him she's present she's loyal she's
committed and he doesn't need her to be
an acrobat he just needs her to be loyal
so that's where they're coming from it's
not appealing the the sexual promiscuity
actually is a turn off because then that
means if she's doing all this stuff she
got a lot of practice with all these
other guys that's not special to me
anymore that's not that's somebody who's
more likely are we talking about sex or
dating sex I'm sorry yeah but I'm gonna
assume that they probably dating if if
she's gone to that step they're probably
dating right probably I mean you never
know yeah yeah probably yeah I don't I
yeah you know what's funny she was
dating a different streamer and then
Destiny came and basically stole his
girl yeah like literally she was dating
another streamer and then Destiny came
to town to like hang out with them and
they let Destiny stay on their couch and
then it was actually so sad I watched
this Destiny was screwing Molina in the
other room while the old streamer was on
the couch yeah like literally it's not
it's on like YouTube yeah and it's funny
because it's like and then she doesn't
see why you'd be more likely to leave if
you're promiscuous when in her last
relationship she's literally evidence of
them yeah she literally laughed because
she was having sex with Destiny while in
a relationship with another guy even
deeper than that it's we always we
always look at these topics on the very
surface level of it it's the way I look
at it is that doesn't realize that the
woman he sleeps with is one of the
easiest ways that his enemy can get to
him is is not worth anything because
like how else can you like if a man is
worth anything on Earth one of the
easiest ways you can get to him is
through the people closest to him and
who is closer to any man than the woman
he sleeps with so if that woman is easy
like sex is accessible to the whole
world then the man
that's so true
sense to me
no because if she's picked to be with
you after all these guys isn't that
special because she picked you instead
of all these pictures for now that's
like you did with your ex until we found
destiny
that's how I view it it's like she she
picked that person she went through 100
and didn't like any of them as much as
she likes the last one and then she has
all these experiences but you know
what's crazy I've talked to girls that
have slept with like 50 to 100 guys and
they'll openly admit this they say they
only loved roughly five so it's like
there's only five that really like out
of a hundred dudes there's only and
that's what I realized I'm like I think
women have roughly like five chances at
love because like they did all this sex
right but they couldn't fall in love
after five times yeah and there's the
studies to prove that when you look at
things like pair bonding I know yeah
there's a bit of controversy around
those studies but it when I look at the
patterns in the data it makes sense to
me especially given you know the
psychology of females as well especially
with relationship to Children it would
make sense that you are supposed to kind
of latch on to to one person as a female
at least yeah the crazy thing about
about our destiny story is that the only
difference between Destiny's story and
what used to happen in the past is that
Destiny didn't sleep that guy's truth so
that's what happen in the past you come
you you find your way into the guys like
inner Chambers you sleep is true to take
his woman and it's probably really great
in bed well they'll say no because there
was something wrong with her judgment
that she allowed herself to be that open
100 too I'm like how do you find a
hundred dudes you like
you're just damn near like everybody and
that intimate with so many guys you
couldn't have been in love with a
hundred if you're using a 100 is a big
number right yeah that's it let's say
let's say 10 people yeah more normal
maybe I think I think the challenge is
and you know the conversation always
goes when I had this conversation with
Destiny too like virgin or somebody who
slept with like 100 people those are two
extreme cases right do I think that most
guys would take a virgin gladly over
somebody who had slept with 100 people
100 100 but do I think you know they're
going to be opposed to a woman who's
slept with a few guys that she had
relationships with where she did pair
sex with emotion where she was having
something real you guys will take damn
near anything these days they didn't
really have a choice they don't really
they don't have a choice like no guy
expects a virgin guys adapt to the
market because there's studies that that
indicate that it's a need for men so if
it's a need and the whole Market is
non-virgin women like what are they what
are they gonna do and plus especially if
they have to sell themselves to get it
of course they're gonna say they're okay
with non-virgin like I mean what else
are they gonna do die alone and some
guys choose to do that but it's like
guys that want to be in relationships
they got no choice no I think that's
totally okay I think the challenge is
that they worry that if you're able to
disconnect sex some emotion you're more
likely to then cheat in a relationship
you're more likely the second you hit a
roadblock to be somebody who can go
cheat because you're you're wired that
way you're capable of just sexist sex
yeah because sex loses its value at that
point it's then you know sex is just
like oh well I'm going to get a takeaway
from McDonald's I'm gonna go grab a Big
Mac like when you separate the emotional
part from sex and how kind of deep and
personal it is I hate to say the word
sacred but I'm gonna say it anyway I
know it triggers a lot of people but it
is a very sacred thing it's personal
it's emotional when you separate that it
becomes like anything else like getting
a Big Mac like going to the gym well and
it's all to make us into men yeah
because like to men it's not emotional
but they're like it's like jealous
feminist try to make us into the men but
they only see the top percentage of men
so they're trying to be the top 10
percent of men because they have the
most leverage and power and whatever in
society but they don't even see the rest
of men yeah yeah a virgin or somebody
who had sex with two guys and both of
them you've been madly in love with you
don't even know a world outside of sex
paired with love there's a lot of Safety
and Security that a man gets from that
can you feel like I would be a lot more
scared if I had a girlfriend that was a
virgin and no experience like let's say
she goes to work and then she meets
someone else
and they have like a really good
chemistry and a lot of sexual tension I
feel like just because she doesn't know
what that is on the other side she would
be more interested in doing it than if
she is aware of her feelings she's aware
of what she can do and what she wants
because she has like saying I need to
drink alcohol every day I need to get
super drunk for a hundred days in a row
to just prove that I don't want to be an
alcoholic I need to take all the steps
to become an alcoholic just to show I do
not want to be an alcoholic well that's
my old saying isn't it that you you
don't know what you don't know so if you
don't know what's on the other side then
you're not going to be more driven
towards it if you don't know what it is
because it could be just as ugly as it
is pretty I feel like if she picks me it
makes a lot more sense because she she
knows so much better about herself
because she gained so much experience
and learned about herself if that girl
gets to 21 22 23 particularly now given
like what the college experience looks
like and she's still a virgin that is a
girl who you're going to feel really
comfortable going to work and if she
does have a dynamic with somebody that
maybe there's some chemistry she's gonna
she's gonna guard her body so heavily
and treat that so well because because
that's how it works right that's that's
it would be like a huge contrast between
imagine a woman who went through college
went through you know the hookups
culture scene was out with her friends
who were doing that and didn't do it
because she couldn't physically like
that just wasn't something she could do
she didn't feel like casual sex was in
her DNA I think like if you're let's say
you're dating someone from high school
and then you're getting married to that
person and this high school kid let's
say that he grew up and he has been
really what do you call it like his
parents religious like serving
everything for him he doesn't know how
to cook he doesn't know how to clean his
room he doesn't know how to even get a
job or anything like that and then this
girl is like doing pretty fine for
herself but that's like the only thing
she knows and she has this sort of idea
that she wants to have this guy and she
wants to have sex after marriage and
then after they get married and she has
sex with them she meets a guy at work
that has this energy of being in control
and taking I wonder if this has happened
to her sometimes it seems very specific
like sometimes chicks tell stories and
I'm like give themselves away is that is
that what happened been to you like
towels and cleaning it can do all these
amazing things why wouldn't she be
interested just in the personality of
this one guy that seems to have the
together compared to you yeah that's
what I'm saying but like but then she's
already she's already picked someone
from high school a great argument for
why women shouldn't work let's say right
that because she didn't know what she
wanted she didn't want to have she
didn't want to marry a kid right well
that's fine but that's not that that's
not on par with the justification yeah
but I don't really be around but that's
why I don't sleep with 100 guys to
figure out no you don't have to do that
but I think having some sort of
experience is good that's pretty much my
point instead of just having no
experience I don't think with no
experience you know what you want I
think people tell you what you want at
that point I don't know so again no no
experience do women even know what we
want her ideas her own or is it just
what every other woman around her is
reinforced oh that's okay the answer is
not promiscuity right so that we have
two ends of the spectrum now we have
like no experience where you're a virgin
you enter your first relationship that's
the only man that you know that can come
with its own sets of challenges and then
you have someone who's sleeping around
for Hobby and by the time they hit 25
they've been with a ton of guys that
they don't even care about some of whom
they don't even know their last name so
well that could be the case well right
but and all I'm saying is guys the vast
majority of men may not say a virgin is
their first choice maybe they'll say you
know what I'd like a woman who maybe
she's had a couple of relationships that
she's really been invested in it shows
some relationship history shows she
knows a little bit something about
relationship maybe they'll say that but
they're definitely going to pass on this
girl over here that's been with
everybody Under the Sun and they'll take
that virgin over this girl over here any
day of the week because they'll at least
know that that girl is extremely
selective probably comes from the kind
of family that taught her to have
software is female
um experience sexual experience that
important because by Design female
sexual experience female sexual and I
want to be very careful how I say this
but by Design By Nature female sexual
experience is really not necessary for
reproduction yeah that's true like you
need to have sex like once yeah a guy a
guy literally just needs to for
reproduction to happen a woman literally
just has to not do anything yeah start
in her body probably is going to be very
unlikely to stray in the same way and I
know you see it differently but if
you're able to have sex Loosely if
you're able on any level to do that
you're much more of a threat to a man
than someone who's unable to do like I I
was not able I always thought it was
like I was like I'm flawed by Design
there's something wrong with me I used
when I was growing up I actually felt
like I just can't I can't do that like
it it's on it would be uncomfortable for
me to even really like make out with
somebody that I didn't have like a
feeling that made a lot of guys feel
really safe because they knew if they
sent me out and I was hanging out with
my girl like that was I was not going to
Andre it wasn't in my wiring do you
think that there is any other chance for
someone trust you without looking at
your past like that you think that
there's anything you could no I'm sorry
like your past makes you who you are
like we're in the present right what
else would make you who you are other
than the past it's a reflection of your
your value by giving your behavior like
if you went to jail for theft I'd be
like ah I might need to keep Niles you
know what I mean like it's like what do
you
if we don't judge people I get this
whole like oh you know don't judge
people like I want to be nice all of
that but it has no utility if we don't
judge people how do we wean out the bad
from the good and there is such thing as
bad and good because okay someone's gone
to prison for murdering I don't know
children pregnant women something awful
are what you're gonna meet this guy and
but I don't judge his past no you you
have to look at the past you it's it's
important in order to distinguish good
from bad and there is such thing as good
from bad because we can all agree a man
who goes around killing pregnant women
probably not a good guy probably not the
best guy probably not but you know
what's funny we can't agree that a woman
aborting her child is probably not the
best one you know it's funny like if a
man kills a pregnant woman or even just
kills her baby yeah like if he was
walking around like demon but a woman
who kills her own child fine yeah she's
a wifey Yeah okay or show like presently
well I think I think people do change
right and I think like I always say
there are people who change for the
better right they have a past there's
people who women who were promiscuous
and had and only fans and did whatever
and then they hit 30 and they're like
that's not me anymore like I don't want
that do I think those people is it that
they don't want it or they just don't
have the audience anymore because they
got older
I hate to say it like blog China that's
the thing I actually don't believe
people change as much as we like to
chant or is it just that they recognize
their circumstances I think people
barely change people hardly ever change
I think I think men change more than
women like sometimes men will have like
crazy teenage years and grow out of it
and I guess women too but it's like it's
so few well that's the thing men men
don't change because men change men
change because reality forces us to
change yeah but we have created a
society where nothing is forcing women
to change so they are not going to
change because if nothing was forcing
them to change men wouldn't change right
that's so true because every every dude
that I've met that's kind of grown out
or something it's because something
happened to them or like their friend
you know what I mean like they're in a
rough whatever and like or something
happened to their friends yeah whatever
but women it's like living delusion
forever because we reinforce it in each
other and we allow it and we don't hold
each other to standards our fear of
being that mean girl but it's like no
like you need friends friends are people
who can tell you when you're stepping
out of line when you're making a fool of
yourself not someone who's going to
allow you to make a mess of your life
and then go whoa you go girl love that
for you you go ruin your life and men
and men want to get laid so they just
like don't let us and there's
consequences for them then they're a
misogynist and they're you know it's
like and it's so funny once you start to
realize like that men are lying it's
just kind of it's like you could hear
the pandering in their voice you can't
unhear it 100 do I think it's still
really hard for guys to process their
past and come to terms with it I do so
it's like yeah they can change and maybe
that woman would ultimately be an
amazing wife an amazing mom
but there's a lot of guys that won't be
able to get past that promiscuity and
they'll be thinking in their head is
this a liability for me does she like is
her ability to be promiscuous gonna bite
me in the behind in a couple of years so
I think that's just how they feel
whether it's right or wrong that's how
they feel a lot of them is this a tough
lesson today was this was this hard to
understand or was it was it was it a
tough like it was super controversial
right I think it's amazing that we live
in a day and age with seemingly common
sense is deemed controversial and we'll
get millions of views people are like
whoa I've never heard this before
I'm with you chica it's like what this
is we live in this like delusional
reality well they just let us swim and
live in delusion forever I don't like it
it's not nice it's not it's not it's not
nice well guys
um let me know what you think in the
comments how many bodies is Too Many
Bodies let me know in the comments make
sure you go subscribe to Christine's
Channel we're trying to get her to a
thousand subscribers so go do that like
the video on your way out and we'll talk
to you next time